money was like angry yapping and and
this and that i'm in the bathroom oh you
were in the bathroom i was in the
bathroom when i came out the brawl is
already because i'm sipping up my pants
quickly and i'm trying to get to see
what's going on and i see zimmer rushing
towards me and i'm like what he got
close to me said some bad words he
actually tried a job
[Music]
so who we got in the pool hall today
pedro martinez looks good baby all right
all right how you living i'm i'm living
great
watching you ready to play some pool i'm
excited let's get it on boy i've been
playing very very very very long time
you got it
you got one in i got one there you go i
got lucky pedro you're one of my
favorite baseball players of all time i
love
the fiery aggression that you played
with it was just so relatable for me
growing up with nothing and having that
kind of anger growing up as a kid
where did that come from well it's a
long story man but uh our family was a
big family thanks to god
ramon led the way my mom was still
bouncing in the minor leagues as an
elevator for the la dodgers didn't make
any money yet mom and dad were left at
home with me and the rest of the kids
and i was dropped at the academy really
early what is 14 and a half 15 because i
was quick to fight
i could relate
i was really quick to fight any picking
on one of my cousins would be my fight
family members
friends
that would be my fight
there you go he gonna beat my ass
i mean i think most people remember from
an anger perspective the 2003 alcs
is the scenery incident what happened
well i threw a ball behind karine garcia
and my shoulder was hurting
and i met him first and second karin
garcia is a ninth place heater and i'm
trying to rush a fastball opening on him
but i did it out of the slide step and i
took the ball i'm dragging
i'm tired i'm making you can't let the
opposition know that your shoulder hurts
that's food they'll eat you up
exactly so the boy came behind him
instead of in front of him up here came
behind him so when he dug down the ball
hit the bat it looks like the ball is
over his head
so zimmer took obsession to that they
started yapping this and that i
continued to pitch got a ground ball
double play but when karine garcia is
going to second he almost kills the
second baseman he will slide into second
and took my second baseman out i just
said what are you thinking is that two
to one game or three to two something
like that who wants to hit you you crazy
clean it up so posada popped up
zimmer popped up everybody started
yapping on me but i went in got the
inning done roger clemens throws the
ball and money many ramirez and then
manny was gonna take that
money was like angry yapping and and
this and that i'm in the bathroom oh you
were in the bathroom i was in the
bathroom because i came out a little
later when i came out the bra is already
because i'm sipping up my pants quickly
and i'm trying to get to see what's
going on
and that's when i hear the mumbling kind
of behind me and i see zimmer
rushing towards me
and i'm like what and that's when he got
close to me said some bad words that i
didn't expect from zimmer either he
actually tried to jab me so i pulled it
and that's why it looks like i dropped
him
but in reality that's the only blemish i
would love to erase from my career there
hasn't been any other moment where i
felt worse
in my life i was i'll tell you my life
than that moment and that moment led to
a lot more go ahead take a shot
oh we got the touch there yeah there you
go
so when you go back to new york now what
is it like you know what it's a lot
better than than i ever thought people
really realized what i did
how i did it i became a hall of famer
i've done so many other things that
people didn't know they see that my
attitude was different when i wasn't
pitching
like no more tied me to the post what
happened with that well i was like the
lucky charm i'll come out and i will
last for two or three runs they will get
the two or three runs and norma was
hitting like crazy and that day i had
pitch
so i was running the treadmill i was
doing some more exercises in the
clubhouse and i hadn't come out and
normal was i guess all four two normal
did not like that he went and grabbed me
and goes ah you get out here you get out
of here you'll be loud you do whatever
but we need to continue to do that and
norma was really superstitious
so i was so loud all day that even after
we got the game one side even normal got
tired of me being so loud i got to the
post and i kept just yapping and yapping
and yapping and omar and portugal
decided that they had enough they tied
me up to the polls before i realized
what they were doing i'm like tied up
with this heavy tape and i can't move
even though i was
taped to the poles everybody's laughing
because if a line drive goes to the
doghouse i'm dead meat
look at you
[Music]
dirtiest opponent you ever faced
[Music]
a rod or al horford
what's your signature pitch fossil
[Music]
hardest guy to strike out edgar martinez
best pitcher in baseball right now jacob
degrom tostones
funniest team that you've ever had i
would say money
better baseball culture boston or dr i
would say dr favorite latin america
baseball player five seconds ah vladimir
guerrero best fans in baseball
that's a wrap here pedro hey appreciate
you just swinging by here coming by the
pool hall hey it's been an honor
seriously my pleasure thank you very
much appreciate y'all for watching
we out